welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host definition and if the
mind-bending ending of fractured left
you asking a few questions
then don't worry because we have the
answers fractured is directed from the
same mind that brought us the machinist
and similar to that film not everything
is as it seems
throughout this video i'll be breaking
down everything that you need to know
about the film
as well as its ending and what it means
there will be heavy spoilers here so if
you haven't had a chance to watch the
movie yet and don't want to know what
happens then i highly suggest that you
turn off now
make sure you stick around until the end
for my review but without the way i just
want to give a huge thank you for
clicking this video
now let's get into our breakdown of
fractured fractured follows rey and his
family as they come from thanksgiving
everything seems pretty mundane but as
we follow rey's journey
things begin to splinter and the events
of the movie are difficult to fully
discern without closer examination
rey is an unreliable narrator that
suffers from alcoholism
and after his daughter perry falls into
a construction site
he rushes her to the hospital along with
his wife joe passing out from exhaustion
and a head injury gained from diving in
after perry
rey awakens to find his family
completely gone with the hospital staff
unaware that they ever came in
the last thing he remembers is sending
perry and joe down in the elevator to
head for a scan
and from there the tension ramps up from
beginning to end
instantly the movie gripped me and this
plot aesthetic is awesome to watch play
out throughout the duration of the film
we really are as lost as rey desperate
to learn the truth behind exactly what
happened to his family
and for a lack of a better term just how
fractured rey really is
seeing how reckless he acts makes it a
nail-biting 90 minutes
and you really don't know what the
character will do next after a slight
fall from stardom sam worthington has
really found his niche with projects
like this and manhunter unibomber
and he masterfully portrays the extreme
pressure that he's under and just trying
to get to the bottom of exactly what's
happened
he also perfectly portrays just how
unbalanced he is as a character
and the film is masterfully edited to
let us know that not everything is as it
seems
you really get the stress that rey is
under though and there's so many
possibilities of what could be going on
that your mind will be racing throughout
the film and desperately trying to
understand what happened
this is like a movie version of the
twilight zone and rey is pushed to the
brink of insanity trying to discover
what's been going on
he witnesses body parts getting dumped
into his skip doctors that deny his
version of events
and there just seems to be something
wrong about the entire place
it could also be rey's head wound which
he seemingly came into hospital for
and throughout i was second guessing
whether he was crazy or if there was
more than met the eye about the location
after there's no answers he acts irate
and gets sedated and dragged away by
doctors to a room that he's locked into
he breaks out of his holding and from
here manages to get the attention of
police
they believe rey and go into the
hospital but the seniors and dr bertram
deny that rey came in with anyone else
and the whole struggle with the
character sort of feels a bit like
groundhog day
wait where do i know dr bertram from oh
ned ryerson bing cctv footage seems to
show that rey is crazy
and has lip service paid to the fact
that rey had his previous wife and their
unborn child died due to his
carelessness however after he finds
perry's scarf under a bed
a psychiatrist decides to go with him
leading the police to the scene of the
fall
here they discover four more blood than
there could be from rey's head wound and
accuse him of killing the two
the psychiatrist says that rey made up
the dog and as he's already lost his
family before he created an alternate
reality
in order to shield himself from the
truth rey seemingly got angry due to the
argument at the start of the film
and accidentally killed his daughter and
then wife in a rage
and this has all been a delusion he gets
arrested but when a stray dog appears it
confirms that rey may not have been
making this up
and he grabs a gun from policemen and
locks the cops and psychiatrist away
rey heads back to the hospital armed and
ready to go or last of us
on the entire place now at this point i
was massively on board
and though i was probably 70 in the camp
that ray was crazy
there was still a lot of doubt in my
mind as to whether this or maybe a
conspiracy
to hide the truth from the character it
really can't be overstated how
atmospheric fractured is and this style
throughout the film will have you just
as invested in rey as he is in his
family
upon arriving at the hospital ray goes
undercover
kills the security guard and takes the
elevator down that we last saw his wife
and daughter get into
he discovers that the location has been
harvesting organs from people brought in
and finds joe in a wheelchair and perry
about to be operated on by doctors
who say he's not seeing things clearly
they tried to sedate him but after
bursting a gas pipe and igniting it by
shooting a hospital light
he's able to get his family out and
escape with them ray gets away with his
family and they all lived happily ever
oh wait after hallucinating that they're
in the backseat
we see that rey actually kidnapped
someone who was in the middle of surgery
as the psychiatrist said earlier rey had
indeed killed his family and constructed
the events of the film in his mind
in order to shield himself from the
truth their bodies are in the back seat
of his jeep
and have been there the entire time now
throughout the film the signs are there
literally because we see a magazine
article that says
the signs are there this includes a
queue that seems to disappear in the
waiting room
which forces ray to pace up and down it
the fact that rey's wife doesn't know
his daughter's blood type when they're
asked for it
probably because rey doesn't know her
either and perry saying my head is
killing me when re-watching the film
every medical professional in it should
be taken at their word as they outright
tell the true events of the film
which is that rey came in with a head
trauma by himself
began acting erratic and then showed up
once more the next day accusing them of
kidnapping his daughter
we can take from the death of rey's
prior family that they died due to rey's
drunk driving
and his alcoholism returns at the start
of the film when he buys two miniature
bottles of whiskey
this may not have been enough to make
him go all jack torrance in the shining
but however it did push him over the
edge and we see from the beginning when
driving perry to the hospital
that rey again is acting reckless
endangering others and this is likely
the same sort of scenario that caused
the death of his previous wife
rey is a really fractured and broken man
and clearly he was sent over the edge by
the shock of perry's fall which we
learned was caused by his outburst
feeling like he was trapped once more in
a living hell that would see those
around him fall victim due to his
irresponsibility
rey silenced joe and then created a
reality that he could live in
in his mind however his guilt simply
became too much unless it all came
crumbling down to some degree
that doesn't mean that rey has escaped
the fantasy though and it looks like the
character will continue to believe that
his wife and daughter are alive
in order to spare himself some pain he
heads off into the night
leaving the crime scene with a hostage
and on to whatever fantasy his mind
takes him which ends the film
but what did i think of the movie
overall well fractured is a really tense
and personal story that is propped up
massively by its performances
whilst the twist is slightly predictable
purely because of how similar it is to
the machinist
the director's most famous film that
doesn't mean that the ride isn't
enjoyable
worthington may not pull off the
performance that bale did with his
extreme weight loss
but instead he paints out a grounded
father struggling to deal with the
situation that is going on around him
and living life on the edge this is
fractured main selling point
and couple that with the eerie
atmosphere colour tone to the whole film
and dark and lingering shadows and you
have a film that's an enjoyable watch
for fans of psychological thrillers
whilst the twist may not be as
groundbreaking as it could have been say
before the rise of films like fight club
that doesn't still mean that it's
unearned it doesn't feel completely
cheap or out of nowhere
it feels real enthralling and ultimately
it leads to it being a movie that's
worth watching a second time
just to see if you can pick up all of
the clues and signifiers of which there
are many
in the end i did enjoy fractured and
whilst i would still probably choose el
camino to watch over this if you stuck
between the two
that doesn't mean that it's not worth
giving this a go if you're looking for
other films with high production
qualities and great acting
fractured unlike its name is a solid
movie and that's why it gets
an 8 out of 10. now obviously i'd love
to hear your thoughts on fractured and
what you took from the ending
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and make sure you check out my breakdown
of this weekend's other big netflix
release el camino which will be linked
at the end
we've got a spoiler review and also a
breakdown of what was in jesse's letter
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more if you want to
come chat to me on twitter then make
sure you follow me at definition yt
and if you want to join my discord then
make sure you click the link in the
description below
we've got an awesome community that's
made up of people just like you and it's
the best way to stay up to date with the
channel
also just want to let you know that
we're currently giving away a free copy
of spider-man far from home on blu-ray
and all you have to do to be in with a
chance of winning is to like this video
make sure that you subscribe to the
channel and leave your thoughts on
fractured in the comments section below
the winner is going to be chosen
tomorrow on october 15th
so this is your last chance to take part
now best of luck and i'll see you next
time
this is the channel for people who are
mad into movies
so if that's the kind of thing you like
hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this i've been definition
you've been the best and i'll see you
next time take care
[Music]
peace
[Music]
[Music]
you